und jetzt das heute journal
leidet sich heute abend 30 jahre nach
dem abend an dem alles auf der kippe
stand an dem 70.000 menschen fürchten
mussten das aufgerüstete staatsmacht auf
demonstranten schießen würde
und dann geschah das damals nicht die
friedliche revolution wurde unaufhaltsam
guten haben und dann an einem tag an dem
das beste an deutschland gefeiert werden
sollte und das schlimmste in deutschland
die nachrichten beherrschte zwei tote
mindestens zwei verletzte
in halle an der saale der plan des
täters zielte auf noch viel schlimmeres
sein ziel war die versammelte jüdische
gemeinde von halle in ihrer synagoge am
höchsten feiertag des jüdischen jahres
schutzlos dem killer ausgeliefert und
seiner automatischen watt es ist
mittagszeit als mitten in halle schüsse
fallen im eigentlich eher beschaulichen
paulusviertel unweit der synagoge wird
eine frau erschossen
im inneren des gebäudes sind etwa 70 bis
80 menschen versammelt die juden feiern
heute ihren höchsten feiertag yom kippur
das versöhnungsfest und dann hat er es
ist also komplett bewaffnet zu der
maschine werden oder friedhofsmauern
lassen sie haben auch eine explosion
gehört genau die synagoge ist ziel des
angriffs der täter ein 27 jähriger
deutscher versucht in das gebäude
einzudringen filmt seine tat in dem
video das bewusst nicht gezeigt wird
leugnet er den holocaust äußert sich
abfällig über ausländer und frauen
nachdem der angriff hier fehlschlägt
suchte einen neuen tatort nur etwa 600
meter entfernt ein döner imbiss hier
wird ein mann erschossen
der täter ist geflüchtet mit dem fonds
hat halle verlassen und die polizei
konnte außerhalb von halle ein fahrzeug
dann dingfest machen und einen täter
festnehmen
auch im nahe gelegenen landsberg fallen
schüsse einen zusammenhang mit den taten
in halle will die polizei nicht
bestätigen
spricht aber während des gesamten
nachmittags von einer amok lage
in landsberg durchsuchen ermittler
häuser und wohnungen inzwischen hat der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich gezogen
der bundesinnenminister nimmt
schriftlich stellung nach dem
derzeitigen stand der erkenntnisse
müssen wir davon ausgehen dass es sich
zumindest um einen antisemitischen
angriff handelt nach einschätzung des
generalbundesanwalts gibt es ausreichend
anhaltspunkte für einen möglichen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund der
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt hat
eine auslandsreise abgebrochen landet am
abend in berlin es ist so dass zwei
menschen getötet wurden und noch viele
andere menschen auch getötet werden
sollten es gibt denke ich mal nichts
schlimmeres als diese tat so beschreiben
zu müssen diese antisemitischen
hintergrund der sich ja schon abzeichnet
dass also eine religionsgemeinschaft
unsere mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger sich
nicht sicher fühlen können und getötet
werden sollten
das ist für mich etwas furchtbares die
polizei spricht von einem einzeltäter
mit rechtsextremistischer gesinnung der
in die synagoge eindringen und ein
blutbad anrichten wollte es war schon
die rede von einem video das von der tat
existiert der täter hat wie manche
seiner vorbilder muss man annehmen
seine tat sozusagen live ins internet
übertragen wir haben in der redaktion
dieses video gesehen und ausgewertet auf
die fakten die es verrät wir haben uns
entschlossen nichts davon in unserer
sendung zu zeigen solche täter bewegt
auch immer einen drang zur
selbstdarstellung selbst glorifizierung
und dem wollen wir nicht helfen gar
nicht annegret oster ist für uns weiter
in halle an der saale
annegret es war den ganzen tag über
nicht ganz sicher ob es nur ein täter
war oder vielleicht doch mehr als einer
hat sich das geklärt
ja also es ist noch keine offizielle
bestätigung
eingegangen weil es mehren sich alle
anzeichen dahingehend das ist ein
einzeltäter war er hatte vielleicht
begleiter vielleicht mit gewisser das
wissen wir noch nicht aber dadurch sie
sagten dass gerade dass er sich selber
gefilmt hat und natürlich die tat und
das was er gesehen hat sah man auf dem
video was der polizei auch vorliegt das
würde gerade ausgewertet sieht man dass
er eben nicht
weitere menschen hatte die neben ihm mit
waffen versucht haben eben in die
synagoge zu kommen insofern muss man
wohl zum jetzigen zeitpunkt tatsächlich
von einem einzeltäter ausgehend der aus
sachsen anhalt stammen soll deutscher
sein soll und hier in halle gewohnt
haben soll oder wohnt nun haben wir
heute bilder gesehen aus den strassen
von halle wie auffällig wie sichtbar ist
die jüdische gemeinde in halle und vor
allen dingen ihre synagoge die sind nur
gültig am rande der altstadt in halle
sie ist schon sichtbar also man man man
kann hier jetzt im moment nicht rein
laufen aber es ist eine eine offene
straße sie ist nicht versteckt sie ist
offen da eine anwohnerin berichtete uns
von einer dreiviertelstunde
sie fährt sie wohnte sie fährt immer mit
dem rad vorbei sie weiß dass da die
synagoge ist und sie hätte noch niemals
in irgendeiner weise polizei dort
gesehen sicherheit so dass man sich auch
fragen muss warum war es gerade heute
eben an dem bereits erwähnten höchsten
jüdischen feiertag dem versöhnungsfest
eben keine polizei da das wird im moment
massiv kritisiert und wird uns weiter
beschäftigen kann dankeschön annegret
nach halle
gestern abend fand in berlin eine
konferenz der sicherheitsbehörden und
des justizministeriums über die
gefahrenlage aus dem rechtsextremen und
antisemitischen lagerstatt justiz und
gesellschaft gegen rechte gewalt war der
titel dort hielt professor hajo funke
einer der führenden experten das
schlüssel referat
rücknahmen professor funke was schließen
sie aus dem was wir bisher wissen über
die tat auf die motive und den
hintergrund des täters
ich denke zunächst einmal die motivation
eines mörderischen antisemitismus der
kern ideologie der rechtsextrem und der
neonazis in deutschland und weltweit
so wie vor einem jahr in pittsburgh mit
furchtbarem erfolg an die zwanzig
menschen jüdischer herkunft und
jüdischen glaubens erschossen wurden
so wie in christchurch eine moschee
angegriffen worden ist und 50 menschen
erschossen worden sind das ist der kern
nun ist auch dieser täter offenbar
nachdem er bei der synagoge keinen
erfolg hatte nicht reinkommen konnte
wenig weitergelaufen zu einer dönerbude
und hat dort einen menschen als schossen
von dem er nicht annehmen konnte dass er
jude ist es wirkt ziellos und zunächst
zunächst ja aber der kern ist etwas
ungeheures nämlich diese
menschenfeindlichkeit die sich in
solchen ideologien wie dem
antisemitismus oder in der wut auf
flüchtlinge oder in der wut auf die
dönerbude und araber zeigt wie kann eine
gesellschaft sich gegen einen solchen
zunächst fast unsichtbar wachsenden bahn
der dann in mord und totschlag aus
abwehr durch zweierlei die
sicherheitsbehörden das ist auch gestern
sehr stark diskutiert worden müssen sich
dessen stärker gewiss sein dass sie von
einer neuen gefahr auszugehen haben von
netzwerken die fifa zeigt sind zum teil
terroristischen oder wie möglicherweise
in diesem fall nur mit kommunikativen
umwegen und einflüssen arbeiten und er
ein nachahmer täter ist das wissen wir
noch nicht das ist das eine
aber das andere ist dass es eine ende
haben muss mit der hetze etwa eines
bier- und höckel der in seinem
programmatischen buch davon spricht der
million menschen aus dem land haben will
und dies mit ich zitiere wörtlich
wohldosierter wohltemperierter
grausamkeit
das heißt mit sadismus das kann nicht
gehen und das kann auch niemand in der
öffentlichkeit in den medien dulden
wollen das geht nicht das zerstört nicht
nur das gefühl für moral sondern die
gesellschaft und wenn ich ihre
darstellung vorhin richtig verstanden
habe da ordnen sie jetzt diese tat eines
einzeltäters in halle an der saale
also in deutscher provinz ein in taten
die von australien oder neuseeland bis
nach norwegen reichen das ist die
negative seite des internet man guckt
sich das an und hat nachahmer elemente
das sieht man ja auch an dieser tat das
erinnert an kreischefs aber es hat eben
auch an das jüdische anders antijüdische
attentat in pittsburgh kann die
gesellschaft mit dieser hydra fertig
werden mit ihren vielen köpfen
es ist noch keine hydra aber es nimmt zu
wir haben das fanal vom erster september
20 18 in chemnitz als eine bundestags
partei mit rechtsextremen und hooligans
gemeinsame sache gemacht hat und einige
hitler geschrieben haben geschrien haben
wir haben die die revolution chemnitz
gruppe und wir haben den ersten
politischen mord von ganz rechts in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik das heißt
die wir haben sind in gefahr vollen
zeiten wir müssen mehr und anderes tun
beides die sicherheitsbehörden und die
öffentlichkeit dann kann man das
eindämmen und ich hoffe dass das
geschieht
danke für diesen rat des fachmanns
professor funken in solchen situationen
bin ratlosigkeit herrscht über das was
geschehen ist und zu tun ist sind
symbole und gesten von großer bedeutung
[Musik]
die bundeskanzlerin war heute abend bei
der gemeinde bei der großen synagoge von
berlin
[Musik]
der arzt dr josef schuster ist der
vorsitzende des zentralrats der juden in
deutschland wir erreichen ihn jüdischen
gemeindehaus in seiner heimat würzburg
guten abend guten abend herr schuster
hätten wir einen solchen tag kommen
sehen müssen dass eine gewisse furcht da
war dass ich dass der zentralrat der
juden vor entwicklungen ein abgreifen in
ein rechtsextremismus auch in einen
gewaltbereiten rechtsextremismus gewarnt
haben
trotz allem hätte ich nicht erwartet
dass es zu einem tätlichen angriff zu
einem attentat auf eine synagoge kommt
jetzt in halle kommt haben wir hat die
deutsche gesellschaft hat die deutsche
regierung etwas unterschätzt oder
unterlassen in letzter zeit
ich habe schon immer darauf hingewiesen
dass wir in den letzten monat mit
innerhalb der letzten jahre eine
entwicklung haben wo rote linien
verschoben wurden wo also das was man
bislang gedacht hat aber sich nicht
getraut hat zu sagen ja sagt bahr
geworden ist und aus worten folgen taten
das ist ein alte tatsache die sich
leider hier heute auch wieder bereitet
hat um sind solche aussagen immer wieder
auf den entschiedenen protest der
regierungen der medien der mehrheit der
gesellschaft gestoßen aber das hat
offenbar nicht gereicht
es hat offenbar nicht gereicht und dazu
kommt ganz konkret jetzt in halle noch
ein weiterer umstand der mich am meisten
schockiert hat gott sei dank der täter
ist es ihm nicht gelungen durch
technische schutzmaßnahmen eine stabile
tür in das die synagoge einzudringen
aber nicht umsonst finden sich an
jüdischen feiertagen werden
gottesdienstzeiten an sehr vielen
jüdischen gemeindezentrum
polizeistreifen an dass sie da sind es
ein umstand den ich persönlich bedauere
dass es notwendig ist wäre eine
polizeistreife hier in halle vor ort
gewesen dann gehe ich davon aus dass
zumindestens ist gelungen wäre den täter
so früh unschädlich zu machen dass es
nicht mehr zu einem weiteren attentat
und im döner imbiss gekommen wäre
das wirft fragen auf die auch die medien
und die öffentlichkeit wird in den
nächsten tagen stellen werden darüber
hinaus was es von der gesellschaft zu
tun
am tage nach dieser tat von der
gesellschaft ist das zu tun was
unabhängig von dieser tat ist was ganz
eigentlich einfach und vielleicht doch
schwer ist es geht nur um den begriff
der zivilcourage das beginnt im kleinen
wenn am stammtisch antisemitische
rassistische fremdenfeindliche
äußerungen getätigt werden
dann sollte eben der eine auch aufstehen
oder man aufstehen und sagen hey weißt
du was du jetzt eigentlich gesagt hast
meinst du das wirklich ernst meinst du
das geht was du gesagt hast und sowas
ist das ist das was ich zivilcourage
nennen
und wenn es klar wird dass
solche dinge solche äußerung solche
meinungen geächtet werden
ich glaube das wäre ein ganz wichtiger
schritt danke für das gespräch
es war wichtig vielen dank
über alle weiteren aktuellen
entwicklungen halten wir sie in einem
live blog auf dem laufenden
heute.de in unserer planung hatte dieser
tag natürlich eine ganz andere farbe und
die dürfen wir über dem was geschah
nicht vergessen
heute vor 30 jahren begann in leipzig
die erfolgreiche demokratische
revolution und nicht mal die beteiligten
haben geahnt was da von ihnen und mit
ihnen geschah und die welt da draußen
alle außerhalb von leipzig haben es
nicht mal bemerkt weil bilder davon erst
am nächsten tag aus der ddr aus
geschmuggelt wurden 70.000 menschen
demonstrierten damals in frieden die
staatsmacht schlug nicht zurück genau
einen monat später fiel die berliner
mauer ging der kalte krieg zu ende
wir müssen daran denken in leipzig hat
es begonnen und dort wurde heute daran
erinnert bevor sich am frühen nachmittag
der schatten aus halle auf das geschehen
legte und auch danach steffen moritz
bericht tausende lichter erleuchten die
stadt lichter die eigentlich für die
friedliche revolution vor 30 jahren
brennen
heute aber leuchten sie auch für die
opfer des anschlags auf eine synagoge in
halle
er sollte ein emotionales und fröhliches
fest in leipzig werden noch seit heute
mittag sind die gedanken der leipziger
bei ihren nachbarn in halle
ich denke jetzt hat eigentlich im moment
noch bestärkt mal zusammen zu stehen
so einen moment auch mal gemeinsam zu
erleben ich denke mal dass er was noch
mehr verbindet ich glaube es sind doch
auch manche abgesprungen
aus sorge ich habe auch selber über
leicht aber hab gedacht ich lasse mit
dem abend versammeln ich habe mein
freund also kumpel mitgenommen und hab
gesagt wir gehen lassen
auch beim friedensgebet in der
nikolaikirche wurde zuerst der opfer in
halle gedacht
zwei menschen wurden auf offener straße
erschossen
dass das in einer in der nähe einer
synagoge geschah und das auch noch am
jüdischen versöhnungstag jom kippur das
lässt böse ahnungen wach werden gesine
oltmanns ist erschüttert als sie von dem
heutigen anschlag hörte ging sie doch
vor 30 jahren für mehr freiheit und
gegen eine diktatur auf die straße
es war genau am vierten september als
sie mit anderen bürgerrechtlern an der
nikolaikirche unterwegs waren um den
bauch ein plakat entbunden dass sie nach
dem gottesdienst offen zeigte die
forderung nach menschenrechten war zwar
noch kurz zu sehen denn schnell war die
stasi da und entriss ihr das plakat aber
es waren die ersten montagsdemo bilder
die damals um die welt gingen
wir haben eine ganz große freiheit
sehnsucht
wir wollen dass ich das dieses land der
ddr damals verändert ja irgendjemand
muss es ja tun
also das war halt wenn man was zu sagen
hat was sagen möchte dann muss man sich
auch in die erste reihe stellen auch am
19 oktober 89 stand sie in der ersten
reihe voller angst ob sich dieser tag in
gewalt entlädt
doch die angst wechselte die seiten
70.000 menschen waren einfach zu viele
die durch die innenstadt zogen
der bundespräsident würdigte heute
mittag den mut der menschen in der
damaligen ddr warnte aber auch vor einer
spaltung der gesellschaft
ich sehe ein land in dem sich risse auf
thun risse die sich auch in
wahlergebnissen wider spiegeln aber mehr
noch in der art und weise wie wir
übereinander und wie wir über dieses
land reden
nach einer schweigeminute beim lichtfest
hat gesine oltmanns heute ihre kerze
auch für die opfer in halle angezündet
wenn wir denken wenn wir zusammenstehen
und brennen die kerzen heute auch für
die autofahrer so empfinde ich es als
mahnendes dass wir diesen rechten
kräften diesen nationalistischen kräften
keinen raum geben
gegen gewalt sind die leipziger vor 30
jahren auf die straße gegangen
heute haben sie es wieder getan diesen
nachrichten tage in deutschland gehören
auch die neuigkeiten aus dem politischen
alltagsbetrieb der ja weiter
das bundeskabinett hat das umstrittene
klimaschutzpaket verabschiedet damit
soll der klimaschutz in deutschland
gesetzt werden
mit dem gesetzentwurf will die
bundesregierung sicherstellen dass die
deutschen klimaziele für 2030
verbindlich erreicht werden
bis dahin sollen treibhausgasemissionen
um mindestens 55 prozent gegenüber 1990
sinken
als langfristiges ziel verfolgt die
bundesregierung bis 2050
klimaneutralität opposition und
umweltverbände üben heftige kritik
ihnen geht das gesetz nicht weit genug
die bundesregierung hat sich außerdem
auf die wiedereinführung der
meisterpflicht für zwölf berufe geeinigt
gemäss dem gesetzesentwurf von
wirtschaftsminister altmaier sind unter
anderem parkett und fliesenleger
betroffen ebenso wie raumausstatter und
glas veredler so solle die qualität im
handwerk gestärkt werden sagte altmaier
nach der geplatzten pkw-maut gerät
verkehrsminister scheuer weiter unter
druck
jetzt musste sein
ministerium auf anfrage der grünen
weitere gespräche des ministers mit
vertretern zweier mautbetreiber firmen
einräumen im bundestag sollen die
treffen trotz nachfragen der
abgeordneten verschwiegen worden sein
das verkehrsministerium weist die
vorwürfe zurück bei eher informellen
gesprächen bestehe keine
dokumentationspflicht nach der pleite
des britischen mutterkonzerns streicht
die deutsche thomas cook alle reisen für
den rest des jahres auch wenn sie
teilweise oder gänzlich bezahlt wurden
bislang galt der reisestopp bis ende
oktober betroffen sind kunden von unter
anderem neckermann bürgertums und bucher
reisen auch über thomas cook
international gebuchte reisen wurden
abgesagt
der harte praxiskurs von großbritanniens
premier johnson sorgt offenbar auch
innerhalb der regierung für unmut laut
der britischen times drohen fünf
minister mit ihrem rücktritt sollten die
briten ohne vertrag aus der eu
ausscheiden eu chefunterhändler waren
die erklärte vor dem parlament zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt könne man nicht davon
ausgehen noch eine einigung zu finden
kommissionschef juncker schließt dagegen
weiterhin einen deal nicht aus
allerdings akzeptiere er das schwarze
peter spiel nicht dass london begonnen
habe us präsident versucht ein drohendes
amtsenthebungsverfahren mit einer
totalblockade zu verhindern
das weiße haus werde nicht mit dem
us-kongress kooperieren die
demokratische vorsitzende des
repräsentantenhauses pelosi erklärte
dagegen der präsident werde zur
rechenschaft gezogen
er stehe nicht über dem gesetz trump
steht wegen eines telefonats mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten seelands die
unter druck darin soll er diesen gebeten
haben ermittlungen aufzunehmen die dem
demokratischen präsidentschaftsbewerber
beiden schaden könnten
der türkische präsident erdogan hat sich
weder von trumps drohungen noch von
weltweiten appellen bremsen lassen
er macht seine ankündigung wahr heute
eröffnete er eine weitere front im
explosiven mix der kräfte und interessen
in syrien mit
hillary und luftangriffen attackiert
seine armee ziele in den kurdischen
gebieten wie er mit einem von der türkei
beherrschten sperrriegel quer über den
norden des landes eingrenzen das geht
jetzt alles sehr schnell
eigentlich begann das vor nur drei tagen
in einem telefongespräch zwischen
erdogan und trump in dem camp erklärte
dass die usa der türkischen armee nicht
im weg stehen werden wenn sie gegen
kurden immerhin bis dahin verbündete der
usa vorgehen
jetzt wird das durchgezogen thomas gill
berichtet aus istanbul vom schreibtisch
aus spricht der türkische präsident am
arm zu sein soldaten als oberster
befehlshaber der armee
ich wünsche allen die an der operation
beteiligt sind viel glück und viel
erfolg
ich küsse ihre stirn ich glaube fest
daran dass unsere armee gemeinsam mit
unseren historischen verbündeten norden
syriens die terror-organisation tkkg
pg&e es beseelen werden 16 uhr ortszeit
starten vom türkischen flughafen
diyarbakir die ersten kampfjets richtung
syrien
es ist der beginn einer
militärintervention mit der erdogan
seine sicherheitszone durchsetzen will
eine art puffer zu den bewaffneten
kurden milizen unterstützt von der
artillerie bombardiert die türkische
luftwaffe ziele auf einer länge von 120
kilometern zwischen den syrischen
grenzstädten kollabiert und rasseln ihn
noch ist unklar wie tief die türkischen
truppen in syrische gebiet vorrücken
werden
der krisenstab mit erdogan wichtigsten
beratern und ministern kommt am abend
zusammen in den teestuben istanbuls ist
der einmarsch den ganzen tag über das
thema viele unterstützen
wir müssen unsere grenzen schützen das
ist notwendig das bringt unserem land
mehr sicherheit ok eine sicherheitszone
kann es geben aber einen krieg zu führen
und in ein anderes land einzumarschieren
das nicht unser ist nichts erklärt ohne
us luftunterstützung haben die von den
kurden dominierten syrisch
demokratischen kräfte sds wohl kaum eine
chance gegen die türkische armee als
reaktion auf die offensive verkünden sie
die generalmobilmachung ihrer kämpfer
und rufen zum erbitterten widerstand auf
die kurdischen milizen feuern granaten
richtung türkei
nur wenige stunden nach der offensive
verlassen die menschen in nordsyrien
ihre häuser
es sind mittlerweile tausende die sich
aufgemacht haben und nicht wissen wo sie
sicher sind die kurdische
selbstverwaltung bad bereits vor einer
neuen flüchtlingskatastrophe auch in der
nacht gehen die kämpfe weiter
niemand weiß wie lange die offensive
dauern wird operation friedens quelle
hat der türkische präsident erdogan sie
genannt
doch von frieden ist die region heute
weiter entfernt denn je
im gegenteil unser reichen inzwischen
meldungen dass die bodenoffensive mit
dem eindringen türkische bodentruppen
nach syrien begonnen habe nachrichten
nun aus der wirtschaft die deutsche
wettbewerbsfähigkeit lässt nach in der
neuen rangliste des
weltwirtschaftsforums fällt die
bundesrepublik von platz drei auf platz
7 zurück vorne liegen singapur die usa
und hongkong frank bethmann auf welchen
gebieten ist deutschland denn ins
hintertreffen geraten
na ja die antwort wenig überraschend
beim schnellen internet seit jahren
schon ein echtes ärgernis nicht nur für
privatpersonen sondern auch für die
industrie die moderne fertigung die
industrie 4.0 braucht zwingend starke
datenleitungen
doch bei verbindungen über glasfaser und
bei mobilen breitbandanschlüssen
verspielt deutschland eine bessere
platzierung
während die bundesrepublik also bei der
informationstechnologie beim schnellen
internet lahmt erzielt das land laut der
neuen
rangliste in anderen
wettbewerbsrelevanten kategorien wie der
innovationsfähigkeit der inflationsrate
und bei der verschuldung topnoten das
zurückfallen im ranking muss also etwas
relativiert werden dennoch werden die
fehlenden schnellen datenleitungen zu
einem immer größeren standort nachteil
große konzerne wie vw denken laut
darüber nach den ausbau für die eigene
produktion selbst in die hand zu nehmen
und auch die verwaltung in deutschland
hinkt bei der digitalisierung weit
hinterher
per mausklick geht kaum etwas selbst ein
einfacher umzug erfordert einen
persönlichen behördengang so wundert es
nicht dass deutschland auch in einer
anderen rangliste dem digitalisierungs
ranking der eu weiter zurückgefallen ist
und mittlerweile nur noch den 24 von 28
plätzen belegt kleine länder wie island
sind auf diesem wichtigen feld links an
uns vorbeigezogen
vielen dank der bundesgerichtshof hat
die rechte von mietern nach
modernisierungen gestärkt wer sich eine
höhere miete nicht mehr leisten kann
darf nicht pauschal auf eine kleinere
und damit günstigere wohnung verwiesen
werden urteilten die richter
vielmehr müsse jeder einzelfall
umfassend geprüft werden keine einwände
dürften mieter jedoch erheben wenn
modernisierungen aufgrund von schäden
notwendig waren oder der allgemein
übliche wohnstandard hergestellt wurde
der nobelpreis für chemie geht an drei
materialforscher für die entwicklung
lithium-ionen-batterie den handys
laptops und elektrofahrzeugen zum
einsatz kommt die königlich schwedische
akademie der wissenschaften ehrt damit
den us amerikaner john be good enough
den briten stanley whiting helm der auch
us amerikaner iss und dem japaner akira
hoshino der in jena geborene good enough
ist mit 97 jahren der älteste
nobelpreisträger überhaupt und auch an
diesem mittwoch dürfen die gewinnzahlen
vom lotto am mittwoch nicht fehlen sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
2 12 22 32 40 45 superzahl 8 mehr auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text
der nachrichten tag ist auch für uns
noch nicht vorbei wir melden uns um
mitternacht noch einmal und schauen nach
dem aktuellen stand bis dann
[Musik]
guten abend also so richtig kalt ist es
in europa im moment noch nirgends bei
uns gibt es um die 15 grad in
skandinavien immerhin zwischen null und
zehn grad aber am mittelmeer und vor
allem richtung spanien und portugal ist
es mit um die 30 grad noch richtig
sommerlich und genau von hier macht sich
jetzt zum wochenende das azorenhoch so
langsam zu uns breit allerdings erstmal
nur in den süden mit sonne und wärme im
norden bleibt es bei tiefen trug noch
bewölkt und regnerisch vor allem am
freitag und bis dahin hat ohnehin das
wechselhafte wetter noch überall die
oberhand zwar lassen die schauer heute
nacht kurz etwas nach aber in der
zweiten nachthälfte verstärken sie sich
aus dem südwesten schon etwas immerhin
auch der dauerregen an den alpen lässt
jetzt nach dazu gibt es fünf bis zehn
grad bei einem frischen südwestwind und
er nimmt morgen noch etwas zu mit
stürmischen böen auf den bergen und an
der see und dementsprechend schnell
ziehen auch die wolken also es wird
richtig wechselhaft wirklich am morgigen
tag regenschauer sind zwischendurch
überall mal möglich der schwerpunkt
liegt vormittags aber wahrscheinlich
über der mitte und dem südosten
nachmittags dann vor allem über dem
nordwesten wobei das insgesamt morgen
wohl nicht viel ist was da vom himmel
kommt außer vielleicht mal in einem
einzelnen gewitter das ganze gibt es bei
11 bis 17 grad morgen aber ab dann wird
es stück für stück wärmer die
temperaturen aus dem süden her steigen
so dass am sonntag im südwesten 26 grad
also ein sommertag möglich sind was
dieser goldene oktober aber wie gesagt
im norden ankommt ist es da erst mal
noch regnerisch und teils stürmisch